[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
my hero academia video in this video we
will be discussing one of the most
highly requested topics that keeps
popping up in the comments to all of our
boku no hero videos and that is the
question of who is the you a traitor
in this video I will discuss the most
popular theories about the UA traitors
true identity and I will then proceed to
provide some of my own theories as well
before we get started I just want to
make clear that the theories I'm gonna
discuss here are just speculation so
they are not spoilers in and of
themselves however this video will
contain mangas spoilers that I need to
talk about in order to properly explain
all the theories so if you haven't read
the manga proceed with caution if you
enjoy these types of theory videos and
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell and if you
want to help us decide what type of
videos to make next be sure to follow us
on twitter at anime uproar linked in the
description in chapter 83 of the manga
present Mike first brings up the idea
that there must be a traitor at you a
because only the teachers and the pro
hero team the pussycats knew where the
students training camp would be located
and yet the villains found them anyway
in chapter 98 the highly intelligent
principal mezu confirms that he also
thinks that there is a traitor when he
says that making the students live in
dormitories on the UA campus will both
keep the students safe and help to smoke
out the traitor
now there are people who don't think
that there is a traitor at all because
the villains might simply be using a
quirk no one knows about like a
long-range mind-reading quirk or
something along those lines to gather
the information they need however with
the amount of emphasis
has been placed on there being a traitor
in chapters 83 and 98 I think that from
a storytelling perspective it makes
sense to follow through and actually
bring a traitor
into the story assuming that the traitor
is someone we know and not a teacher we
haven't met yet or something along those
lines there have been quite a few
theories out there about which of the
characters we already know could be the
spy and traitor one popular theory that
I've come across quite a bit is that
denki community could be the you a
traitor because his quark
electrification allows him to generate
and manipulate electricity and affect
electronic devices which would make
coming re well suited for the job of a
spy
his quirk could allow him to mess with
electronic devices so that he could
communicate with people without anyone
detecting it and he may also be able to
Jam electronic signals a lot of people
have also pointed out that the original
design for common Aries character was
changed by a horikoshi because he felt
that coming Ari looked too much like a
villain so some are taking this as a
clue that community was intended to be a
villain from the start personally well I
think that community squirt definitely
could come in handy to a spy in the
modern world full of electronic devices
there is just nothing close to solid
evidence or motive for common re to be
the traitor in terms of his original
character design appearing villainous I
think that my hero academia has gone out
of its way numerous times to tell us
that we shouldn't judge a character just
by their appearance so I don't think
that coming on his appearance alone
would be a good argument also the
drawback of coming out as quark is that
if he uses it too much he will
short-circuit his own brain and become
completely useless and helpless for an
hour which would be a terrible drawback
for a villain to have while they're
risking everything to infiltrate the UA
as a traitor now perhaps common areas
drawback is just an elaborate act of
some kind and he doesn't really become
useless after using too much power maybe
he just wants others to see him as
harmless to draw suspicion away from
himself but this just seems to be
stretching it quite far and until we get
additional
evidence I am not prepared to support
the common re trader theory police
detective and all mites friend now masa
su Kochi has also been identified as a
potential suspect because he has close
connections to UA through his friend all
might but since he works for the police
he is able to move about freely in and
out of the school without drawing
suspicion however in order to accept
that su Kochi could be the traitor we
have to also accept that he was able to
fool veteran pro heroes like all might
and gran torino into trusting him for
years
this would make all might look like a
pretty terrible judge of characters
since he even trusted su coche enough to
tell him the secret of what for all and
from everything we've seen about su
coche he seems to be doing his best to
track down and stop the villains rather
than help them so I would need a major
piece of evidence suggesting that su
Kochi has been lying or something like
that before I believe that he could be
the traitor he does sheesh in Seoul from
class one scene or the general
department at UA has been identified by
some as a potential traitor suspect and
this accusation stems mostly from the
nature of his brainwashing work which
allows him to control anyone that
replies to one of his questions verbally
now obviously a quirk like this would be
incredibly useful for a spy as he could
manipulate people into revealing
sensitive information and he could also
force them to do whatever he wants in
fact because of the type of quirk he has
as a child Shin so was teased by other
children who told him that he would end
up becoming a villain and Shin soul is
shown to be resentful of other UA
students who have quirks that are more
suited to being a hero than his own is
it is also possible that because his
quirk works only on living creatures the
reason that he couldn't get into the you
a hero program is because the entrance
exam involved robotic opponents which
essentially made Shinto squirt useless
is it possible that Shin Sol thought
this was unfair and became so resentful
that he decided to take his revenge on
the whole system by becoming a villain
yes it is possible but we have to
remember that from what we know about
shin so so far we can see that he goes
out of his way to show that he wants to
be a hero
despite the nature of his work to me he
seems more interested in proving
everyone wrong by being heroic rather
than giving up and becoming a villain
but let me know what you think about
Shinzo and where his story will go from
here in the comments below the next
suspect is foo me Coggan
Takuya me my good friend and fellow
youtuber Ngoc stock who hasn't read the
manga yet even though he really likes
the anime but he thinks that Tok Leon he
looks like a good logical suspect to be
the you a traitor because of his
character design and mysterious quirk
and while it is true that the fact that
toh kweh ami loses control of his quirk
dark shadow at times can be seen as
suspicious for example we know that at
night when his work is most powerful and
at times when toh kweh ami is feeling
strong emotions like anger dark shadow
can actually take over and go on a wild
rampage like ended during the school
trip art however we should also remember
that during the same school trip arc the
villains actually tried to kidnap
Takayama along with Bakugan because they
thought that his quirk looked very
impressive so it seems that the Vanguard
action squad at the very least did not
have prior knowledge of toh kweh ami
which would imply that he is not one of
them again there is no evidence that Tok
Mohammed is the traitor and for that
reason I am not prepared to accept this
theory some people have also suggested
that teachers like ectoplasm may be the
traitor because ectoplasm just looks so
much like a villain but again I strongly
feel that my hero academia teaches us
that we should never judge someone as a
person just by their looks or by their
quirk so I don't think that someone's
supposedly looking like a villain or
having a quirk that looks like it will
be good for a villain means that they
are the traitor probably the best you a
traitor theory that I've come across
thus far is that the Invisible Girl
Tohru hakurei is the you a traitor in
fact in a very well researched and
comprehensive video a youtuber known as
joy boy theories made a strong case for
Tohru being the you a traitor I will
leave a link to this video into the
scrip
I definitely recommend checking it out
but to sum up his arguments quickly he
points out that Toru is never seen
directly fighting against the villains
in Chapter 12 she appears to be absent
from the school at a very conspicuous
time on the same day that the villains
breached UA during the usj arc toros
location is unknown for the entire time
afterwards she claims that she was
transported to the landslide area but
there is evidence that she might be
lying about this and this is because the
landslide area is the place where
Todoroki was also transported and he
froze the entire area as soon as he
arrived and yet totem does not appear to
have been frozen Tohru was also the one
who first suggested that members of
class 1-a should go shopping together
and on that very same day at that same
shopping mall shigaraki confronts Deku
the implication here is that shigaraki
knew he would find Deku there because
Tohru gave him a heads up
finally Tohru could have potentially
contacted the villains during the school
trip arc and informed them about the
location of the lodge however even
though these are really interesting
arguments there is no smoking gun here
as much of it could be explained away as
horikoshi is simply not bothering to
give us enough info about Tohru and her
activities just yet the shopping mall
encounter between shigaraki and Deku
could also be explained away by the fact
that many people recognized class 1a
students right away because they watch
them fight in the tournament so
technically any of these random people
could have informed shigaraki that Deku
wasn't at the mall at any rate joyboy
theories goes into the arguments in much
greater detail so check that out if
you're interested in this theory in
particular and I also like the fact that
he pronounces my hero academia the same
way that I do
but if Tohru is the traitor it is likely
that there is more than one trader at UA
because during the hideout raid arc
all-4-one somehow appeared to know ahead
of time what the plans of the police
were despite the fact that at this time
Tohru would not have access to
disinformation what other thing that I
thought of while thinking about Toto as
the traitor is what her motivations
could possibly be if she was just a
regular student
why would she possibly want to work with
the villains we don't know enough about
her background to know if she has an
ordinary family situation or if
something is off there because
presumably if she has normal parents
that she lives with they would not want
her to have anything to do with villains
but there is a potential wildcard and
that is the fact that the only other
character besides Toto that we know can
turn themselves invisible is league of
villains member kimmykak toga toga
squirt transform allows her to change
her appearance to look like another
person if she consumes enough of their
blood but as we learned during the hero
license exam arc toga can also become
invisible if she holds her breath and
keeps her mind clear if we remember that
similar quirks tend to run in the family
in the world of my hero academia then
perhaps toga is somehow related to Tohru
again no direct evidence for this but if
this were true it would begin to give us
some potential motive for why Tohru
would want to become a traitor I will
talk more about toga at the end of this
video but now let's discuss the next
suspect the next traitor suspect that I
want to talk about is none other than
principal mezu himself mezu is the only
animal we know of that has a quirk his
quirk of course gives him incredibly
high intelligence and we know that he
has the physical features of multiple
animals including a bear a dog and a
mouse and speaking of mice in chapter
158 of the manga we learned at one
theory states that the origin of all
quirks was a virus that might have been
carried by mice and then spread to
humans this to me suggests that mice
were being experimented on by humans as
mice are commonly used for scientific
fermentation perhaps humans were
experimenting on mice in an attempt to
create some sort of super soldier for
the military or something along those
lines and the result was a virus which
led to the development of quirks a virus
which was later spread to humans since
the structure of a virus can change in
the body of every individual host it
would make sense for different people
with this virus to develop completely
different quirks
during the final exams Ark we learned
that mezu was mistreated by humans at
some point in his life and for this
reason when he is in combat he can be
very devious and even enjoys toying with
humans so what if this abuse at the
hands of humans was actually some form
of experimentation and these experiments
are the reason why he developed a quirk
in the first place despite the fact that
he is an animal furthermore it is
important to remember at this point that
the nomal were once normal humans who
were experimented on by all-4-one and
infused with the DNA of multiple
different people until these creatures
were no longer able to think for
themselves and were only capable of
obeying commands so what if principle
mezu was an early nomu experiment what
if Mezo is an animal no moon infused
with the DNA of multiple different
animals which would explain both why he
has the features of multiple animals and
why he is the only animal we know with a
quirk perhaps mezu was an early version
of the know move before the process was
perfected and instead of making him
incapable of thinking for himself the
experiment actually made him extremely
intelligent by accident we know that
principle mezu has intimate knowledge of
the UAE so much so that if he was the
traitor we wouldn't need a second
suspect he would be enough this is
because nez who had access to both the
information about where the student
lodge was located during the school trip
art and the information about the plans
of the police during the hideout raid
Ark so he could definitely be the
traitor but even though this theory came
to me organically as I was researching
for this video I still have one big
problem with it
mezu seems like a truly nice person
overall who genuinely cares about the UA
students so why would he possibly put
the lives of his students at risk and
side with the villains well think about
this what if Nessa is the traitor but he
isn't actually a villain what if all for
one did indeed experiment on mezu and
somehow manipulated him into leaking
information to the villains what if
during the experiments sometime in the
past
all-4-one was somehow able to brainwash
Nessa into reporting back to him without
even realizing it or what if all for one
implanted some sort of device into naisu
that mezu doesn't even know about and
this device is allowing all for one to
monitor NASA's actions I am hesitant to
believe that mezu is a truly evil
character but I can definitely see him
being an unwitting and/or unwilling
trainer in this case let me know what
you think of the principal mezu traitor
theory down below it is definitely the
theory that I personally think is most
likely at this point after all principal
mezzos mysterious background his strange
appearance which seems to indicate some
sort of experimentation coupled with the
fact that he had all the information
that the traitor would have required
really does make me think that he could
be the traitor finally I will leave you
with a theory that is completely
outlandish and I don't expect you to
believe it for a second but it
came to me suddenly and it was so crazy
that I just had to share it just for fun
what if Toru hakurei doesn't even exist
in the more recent my hero academia
chapters we saw Himiko toga and twice
working together and scheming against
the eight precepts and of course we know
about the existence of the drug trigger
which amplifies to a massive extent the
power of quirks we also know that toga
has the ability to temporarily turn
invisible and we know that twice has the
power to create clones out of other
people so what if at some point in the
past
twice cloned toga and with the help of
the drug trigger this second toga was
able to remain invisible for longer
periods of time
and she infiltrated the UA as Toru huh
Kagura we can safely assume that the
traitor was infiltrated into the UA by
all-4-one himself as she kuraki seems to
have no knowledge of the traitor and of
course all for one has a habit of
concealing certain important facts from
Shigure Aki
this crazy theory that Toru is actually
a toga clone assumes that all four one
came into contact with toga and twice
before they ever met she got Aki and
organized this whole thing well ahead of
time this theory also assumes that Tohru
does not have parents or extended family
that can vouch for her actually being
who she says she is unless the real
Tohru does exist but was at some point
kidnapped by all-4-one and replaced with
the toga clone while this theory would
solve the problem of motive or the lack
thereof for total becoming the traitor
it is so outlandish that I don't
actually expect you to believe it and I
only shared it with you just for fun but
I do think that something like this
would be an insane plot twist that
no one would see coming but that is it
for this video guys there are clearly a
lot of interesting theories out there
personally I think that principle mezu
is the traitor even though he might not
actually be aware of it feel free to let
me know what you think down in the
comments I really want to get a good
discussion going did I miss any suspects
that you think could be the traitor let
me know down below if you enjoy these
types of videos and want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and click that
notification bell also feel free to
follow us on twitter at anime upper to
help us decide which videos to make next
and until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]